it's time to clear this desktop if we
don't do this your creative growth is in
jeopardy Wow
for years rent has been working up with
with janky old door desk he's got all
these really cool props and gadgets and
things like that that he needs that he
likes to keep on his desk but I really
just cannot stand the cable management
the way that it's a door that's propped
up on metal pieces really gets to me
going to make the ultimate render eyes
desk a modded desk built specifically
for rent I'm warming up to the idea but
it's just gonna it's gonna take a minute
[Applause]
that was easy
but what Jake is annoyed by holy grant
use of yes let's put a light yes for the
extra light can't wrap his mind around
right it's this these things here my
desk is C clamp two legs the legs are
the C clamp yep yes this is where our
clamps went he's in love with this thing
I mean everything from the history of it
to the work that he's already put into
it to the man-hours just spent making
cool stuff on this surface so we're
gonna preserve that you might remember
last year I built him this huge electric
skateboard that was super fun and he
likes to ride one wheel all the time
we're gonna incorporate both a place for
the electric skateboard and a place for
the one wheel in here in addition Bren
has a three monitor setup and is often
working off of two computers so there's
gonna be plenty of room for that plenty
of room for building plenty room for
gadgets and we're gonna maintain the
historical sentimental significance of
this here desk
I'll stain it all I'll get a fresh stain
and a fresh coat of varnish and finish
so it will all look like it's one piece
and the first thing that I have to do is
sand it all down
[Music]
we try let me put on my hat what do you
guys think of this hat do you like it
because if you do we'll sell it it's not
out yet don't go running off to the
store just yet anyway that's not what
I'm here to talk about I'm here to talk
about Friday's video we're shooting a
video gonna involve Adrian it's gonna
involve Nikko it's gonna involve our
friend Freddie coming off of the rock
production Adrian and Nikko wanted to do
something that was a little bit more fun
a little bit more humorous so they came
up with this ridiculous idea about how
there's two cops in a fight they need to
do the most ridiculous extreme reloads
to take out all the bad guys it's very
important that both Nikko and Adrian
work together to come up with the best
way to shoot those sequences because
that's gonna make the whole piece hit
home they are unable to work together on
this it's gonna make the video fall flat
there's a girl tied up like Freddy
standing there he's like you only have
five seconds so coming on the door I'm
trying to do the ropes in the person the
children like talked himself in like
some dudes come in bang bang bang
Freddy's gun locks back empty and pretty
girls or like does that me like this is
go up and lengthen I shoot a guy at the
hostage just like he's into that more
guys come running in we fight those guys
and just I'm afraid he's empty he
doesn't like a fancy yellow
so that's how it's gonna be like an
elevating game of course where we're on
the same side instead of pose neck
school today for shot I would have be a
shot that sets up the pressures banging
on the door so the goons are even closer
even more present then the second shot I
would have be the first character
introduction which probably mean about
me
you see who you're dealing with you see
that but gun obviously I'm nervous you
see I'm sweating see I'm a cop close but
I feel like the first the very opening
shot we need to do something that hooks
them like that's super cool so I was
imagining you sliding into frame and
then you finishing like two guys four
already in there and Bernie's already
you know reloading maybe you know ice
for the first the first opening to be
like as if you're coming into the action
sequence and you've missed like the
first half we are now entering phase two
of rennes epic desk build and today
we're gonna pick up some hardware so
that we can fit the world's largest
electric skateboard on the front of it
I'm gonna put the board itself like at
an angle an angle in there the thing is
that how wide is the board I'd have to
go to it I'm going into a desk that I
made out of doors gotcha
[Music]
all right you remember how I was worried
about the sides of the best being a
little wobbly yeah
well that isn't a problem whatsoever at
all keep that off of a boat dude this
thing's got great bones check it check
this out feel how solid this is oh wow
this is so sturdy oh don't don't like
jump on it with all your force desk
Brenda is that this is the bones all
right let's move it up right and I want
to talk about what is viewing it next
because I realized something there is no
chance of this desk looking pretty
I trusted you Jake
but don't worry Ren you're pretty enough
to make up for the ugly desk and we're
gonna go straight for function okay
crazy kids we're gonna rename the title
of this video to the Ren's extremely
functional desk mod it has all look at
all this room in the middle I eliminated
the problem of sink in the middle by
adding the support beam great you know
how used to bow in the middle yeah it's
a problem of the past my friend cool
your knees I'm gonna hit it you're gonna
be fine I'm gonna run just for you
surge protectors you only need to deal
with two outlets at the base of the desk
so you're so it's gonna be super easy to
take things on and off your desk without
having to fumble around on the ground
mess with cables and then up here
underneath right here will be our cable
management it's gonna be sick dude
how I originally embrace the fact that
the electric skateboard the world's
largest electric skateboard was going to
be ugly and not functional for time it
became beautiful and functional we're
doing the opposite here okay it's
becoming more functional but the more
function we have the less beauty we have
you can see that electric skateboard
video just link below Jake when you
started this
you promised me it would look pretty you
pinky promised it would look pretty
beautiful beauty is in the eye of the
beholder my friend I don't want to tell
you because I did not break my promise
it's gonna be so functional it's gonna
be a thing of beauty remember those days
when he used to shoot like the Stevens
moves your friends that was cool
like this is it yeah no just like take a
second okay who's looking where is he
getting the bags from the dead body
whoops it here yes walking like no
weights turn around and like I agree
have a bag yeah and I like the way like
come on I end up with both making he has
a gun and I'm just going like he read
out the reloads which is the most
challenging part of this I've broken
down like action into bite-sized chunks
so many times now that like that's not
really it's hard for me but the creative
aspect of this stuff it's really the
true challenge which is that's where my
crazy reload how does Freddie heaven
even crazier reload what can he do that
special when we have the guys of rifle
and he run up to him and we try to
reload his right from what can we do
with him that special like or another
great examples when Freddie and I start
struggling over the gun like doing the
whole like trying to jam the Megan and
like constantly blocking and dodging
like that's getting creative in the
moment and that stuff's really important
to come up with
[Music]
in concrete oh snap you're drilling
through that one drill through that one
the desk this is Ren's highly functional
desk mud you ready that is scary
housed um usually a whole lot of a drill
but these arrived protection I don't
know I haven't totally on to it I was
focused more on how it was drilling that
I was on the drill itself well kid you
made the sizzle so the key to a good cut
is that you do from both sides and hang
on hang on
don't look don't look get ready Ren's
highly functional despot is now complete
ready you could join me
a giant skateboard as the back of your
desk is like the coolest thing I will
actually you know when you store it the
other way because the walkway to the
camera room is right here but just for
the looks I have the wheels what do you
need to start the other way but my
favorite features okay you like to pull
in in the morning on your one wheel well
guess what
got that charger ready for you right
there alright that's my kind of parking
spot pretty nifty
that's super nifty you got power strip
here and powered ship here I'm gonna
replace that green hey it's still
industrial and you don't have to worry
about keeping it nice you can just do
whatever you got to do desk is complete
I think it turned out wonderfully let me
show you guys what I did first and
foremost rented like a smooth surface
here on the top so I just sanded
everything down really nicely after I
found out that the stain wasn't really
gonna take I wanted to go for just the
complete industrial look and I think
that really comes through with the
sanding that I did here I was also able
to preserve the Omega symbol which is
one of the things that Renton liked
about the desk I decided not to replace
this monitor stand because well it was
well built and it was working fine next
thing that I did I used Carmichael's old
door desk to make the actual feet of the
desk itself now when I first bought
those on there was a little wobbly so I
went ahead and I put brackets here to
help stabilize the legs in addition I
included a large cross beam that goes
from one leg to the other does a couple
things number one it stabilizes the
sides and then number two it prevents
the desk from bowing when there's a lot
of weight in the middle I included an
electrical hole here for the one-wheel
charger included two different surge
protectors one on each side of the desk
now in order to make it as simple as
possible I
connected the surge protectors together
which I know is kind of a surge
protector fro faux pas but we're running
surge protectors into a battery
protector which goes into a closed
circuit so I think it's gonna be just
fine
now he only has to worry about
unplugging one cable when he wants to
move to death then obviously I included
hooks for the electric skateboard which
makes it real easy to take off and put
back on so you can actually use it
however much you want included monitor
holes here which go straight down and
then over to either sides to connect any
electric hole that you have on top here
so anyway I think we made great use of
parts that we already had here we made
the thing more sturdy it's way more
efficient it's built for what rent
actually does rather than using the old
C clamps that we were using previously
which obviously were super janky the
point of the giant board is that this
desk could in theory when the point of
the joint is that Wren just loves his
Electric skateboards to channel some
super huge wall Jake built in the
world's biggest let's go get to work
Andrew yes we've important things to do
I can't be distracted by this
fascinating desk apparatus
pitch deck is done yes what beast please
you don't know I think the worst thing
into the Internet's doing people right
now it's leading everybody to believe
that everybody else is an idiot
especially people that disagree with
them everybody's first reaction is
somebody that disagrees with them it's
like oh you're an idiot it's like
actually the vast majority of people
aren't idiots they just either are
coming from a different background
having a belief system have different
reasons have different like whole
variety of things assuming that somebody
else they may be it especially when
they're professional in their field is
like the worst mistake one person can
make if every stops just Amelie claiming
every else is an idiot I think the world
to be a better place Eliza now picks
which songs she likes to listen to on
YouTube in which he doesn't like a song
she doesn't know fine and I flip the
song fine